[Music]
neighbors - fantastic cast she got Seth
Rogen you got Rose Byrne Zac Efron is in
this you know did you have you did you
and Zach get along Zac Efron he seems
like a pretty fun guy he's the nicest
most sincere guy but recently had a bit
of an awkward situation with him and
that we were doing press we were doing
the press junket but we were in
different groups that they were
interviewing us we didn't really get to
see him and unbeknownst to me he was
taking over the neighbors snapchat which
is like a new thing that we you can do
now and so he comes over any interrupts
our interview and he gives us all hugs
but we're sitting down so he gives me
any other sort of girls kerosene Chloe
he gives us hugs from behind and then he
disappears into the night like the Sally
and that he is you don't see him for the
rest day that's a fun it's a fun he did
a quick fun thing like burst into the
interview the next day he comes up to me
and he's like beanie I'm so sorry I was
like hey Zack what's going on and he's
like I was pre watching the snapchat and
I think I touched your boob I'm so sorry
I am so he's horrified he was like I am
so sorry and in my head I'm like okay
Zac Efron touched my boob and I missed
it
[Laughter]
great it's funny the detail I seized on
was I was rewatching he's sitting there
going through this over and over again
you